the coast guard today plans to recover
the sunken tour boat from last week's
deadly accident near Branson Missouri
the amphibious boat duck boat the
amphibious duck boat rather went under
in hurricane-force winds during a severe
storm this tape was still so hard to
watch seventeen of the 31 people on
board died and there are growing
questions about the safety precautions
on that boat
Omar Villafranca is at the table rock
lake that's the scene of Thursday's
disaster Omar good morning to you good
morning the Coast Guard has this part of
the lake kind of blocked off you can see
behind me there's a patrol boat that's
keeping us about 100 yards back because
just beyond that that's where the boat
actually sunk and it's it's so close
that you can see the shoreline the focus
of this investigation is now what was
happening on the boat divers have
already recovered the black box and the
onboard camera investigators are just
hoping that that information has not
been destroyed and we're starting to
hear from survivors who are talking
about the safety situation on the boat a
church bell rang 17 times at a memorial
service Sunday afternoon each time
remembering the 17 people who died after
the tour boat they were on sank near
Branson Missouri on Thursday always
remain hurt the NTSB is now looking into
what the captain knew about the weather
before heat and 30 passengers faced 73
mile-per-hour wind gusts and 4 to 6 foot
waves survivor Tia Coleman lost nine of
her family members
she's stunned by what she claims the
captain said about the life jackets on
board
he said i'ma show you where they are
where they are but you won't need them
so no need to worry so we didn't grab
Ripley Entertainment which owns ride the
duck stores in Branson hired a private
inspector to examine 24 of its
amphibious boats in August of last year
the first reaction was oh my god Steve
Paul who inspected the boats says he
explained to the company that the engine
exhaust pipes at the front of the boat
could allow water to get in during rough
weather causing the vehicles engines to
fail no four
Elson the boats not gonna move after the
sinking of a duck boat nearly 20 years
ago that killed 13 people in Arkansas
the NTSB recommended adding more
flotation capacity and removing canopies
which traps some of the vehicles
passengers as it sank video of the
Missouri duck boats canopy shows many of
the plastic canopy windows closed
moments before it sank there is an
emergency release that the windows will
actually drop off the vessel and it's
part of our investigation to see if that
method was employed now we're wearing
life jackets but there were also life
jackets on the duck boat but passengers
were not required to wear them it's also
worth noting that the Missouri Highway
Patrol is conducting their own
investigation looking into possible
criminal negligence but it's worth
noting that no charges have been filed
also the boat that sank was inspected
and passed the inspection from the Coast
Guard last year and if there's any
absolutely any good news in this story
is that everyone who was injured and was
in the hospital is now out Nora
Wow Omar thank you so much I just think
about that story I mean a mother losing
her entire family there's a whole
hashtag for her Nora that pray for Tia
Coleman is her name she says she doesn't
know how she can recover from this can
you imagine going home and your whole
family's wiped up she said I don't even
know where to begin to process something
like this it's heartbreaking all the way
around there's a lot of former federal
investigators as duck boats should be
banned